Adam Sarna is a bit like Marmite you
either love him or you hate him however
his entourage continues to get bigger
his films get sillier and now it looks
like he wants in on your Netflix and
chill I'm Simon and this is your
entertainment news update following a
teaser in March Netflix released the
first full-length trailer for Adam
Sandler's next movie the do-over the
movie stars funny mens sana and David
Spade who play characters who are old
friends tired with their boring lives
they reunited their 25th highschool
reunion for the ultimate Mulligan they
faked their deaths to get a fresh start
but things don't go to plan the movies
tagline is dying was their first mistake
and the trailer begins to explain why
the do-over was directed by Steven Brill
who also helmed Sandler movies mr. deeds
and Little Nicky the movie opens on May
27 which is memorial day the movie has
big shoes to fill asanas the ridiculous
six was netflix most popular movie in
its history despite poor reviews and
controversy regarding its depiction of
Native Americans the comedy tallied more
views during its first 30 days than any
other netflix movie Sylas deal with
Netflix is 44 total films meaning two
more are coming after the do-over
according to Deadline Sandler said back
in 2014 when the deal was announced when
these fine people came to me with an
offer to make four movies for them I
immediately said yes for one reason and
one reason only Netflix rhymes with wet
chicks let the streaming begin are you
tired of sauna & Co so-called funny
films or are you hungry for all the
Happy Madison Netflix will feature let
me know in the comments or come find me
on Twitter I'm at the j connaught thanks
for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot